- Did you ever share a spot of tea?
'Cause I love, I've had
wine with Kevin Hart.
And I know that you were
making Diehard together,
and I love this whole
concept of this show.
So like have you ever had tea with him?
- Well, like on set he, do you know what?
He actually introduced me to some tea.
He would send someone to
get a specific tea every day
and it was like peach and like mint
or peppermint and peach fruity thing.
- (laughing) Kevin Hart
drinks a fruity (laughing).
- But it was great, 'cause
it was like really good.
It kind of cleared your source
of airways and the sinuses.
And it was great.
Like, especially when you're
on and we were filming
in Atlanta and it was quite
cold and quite like wet
and damp at the time.
- Any kind of mint, yeah.
- Like slightly sweet, kind of
aromatic tea was quite good.
But he liked to tease
me because I always had
my little eco cup thing
with different teas.
And he'd be like, oh,
are you drinking tea?
You know like, 'cause I
always, always had that cup.
- I know, but it's not
just the tea tastes good.
Like it's really healing,
like it's medicine.
And in some forms like
elderberry, echinacea,
like there's so many
things like silver needle.
All these things are
like really good for you.